in her forthcoming book hillary clinton  says that or implies that bernie sanders  is a sexist and a misogynist she says i  know the kind of things he says about  women and to women this is not an  allegation i've ever heard made against  bernie sanders before and it will be  interesting to see what if any fallout  there is now one of the really  disappointing things is  in reaction  to the news that hillary clinton says  this  a whole bunch of people said horribly  sexist and misogynistic things about  hillary clinton  it's completely fair to ask hillary  clinton for proof  it's completely fair to say wow that  goes against everything i knew about  bernie i wonder if that's really the  truth that is all fair game  but  when you start saying sexist  misogynistic things about hillary  clinton because she makes these claims  you're kind of just making yourself look  really bad